[Musica]
una mattina mi sono stato o bella ciao
bella ciao bella ciao ciao ciao una
mattina stavo potro marzo il passo fu
partigiano portami via o della ciao
bella ciao bella ciao ciao ciao
partigiano portami via che mi sento il
muro da partigiano bella ciao bella ciao
bella ciao ciao ciao e sei un partigiano
[Musica]
di seppellire
massimo compagna o bella ciao bella ciao
bella ciao ciao seppellire massimo
antonio solo chi passerà o bella ciao
bella ciao ciao ciao e laghetti chi
passerò mo mi dirò io tu 20
chi passerà io del partigiano bella ciao
bella ciao bella ciao ciao ciao messo il
fiore del partigiano molto per questo
fiore del partigiano morto per la
[Musica]
è vero
[Risate]
[Musica]
ma c'è anche la sosta mi ha picchiato